our speaker tonight is Li Habib mr.
Habib is vice president of content at
sales Media Group which syndicates
national talk shows hosted by Hugh
Hewitt dennis prager larry elder
sebastian Gorka Mike Gallagher and Eric
Metaxas a University of Virginia School
of Law graduate mr. Habib is the founder
of American private radio and host of
its storytelling show our American
stories a weekday radio show syndicated
across the United States he is a weekly
columnist for Newsweek and he has
written for numerous other publications
including national review the Federer's
and life set he is speaking this evening
about understanding America through its
stories please join me in welcoming Lee
Habib
[Applause]
thank you so much before I start on the
formal presentation just as stories the
power story is what we're gonna really
be talking about today I have a daughter
who in the seventh grade was about to go
into the eighth grade and she had a
boyfriend the point friend was something
she when somebody's went to get ice
cream what that was it with adult
supervision and he was going into high
school and so one day it was Saturday it
was the day she were going to get ice
cream and I would sit at the corner and
she said that I don't feel like it ice
cream today why don't we go to the
movies what's going on sweetheart she
goes up I'm not going out with my
boyfriend but he's going to high school
he's gonna go there and this is gonna
break them but me so I go so this is a
pre-emptive breakup and so I thought I
did this in front of my wife and
everyone still out on them telling
stories in front of my wife my wife says
this husband's here gonna test what are
you thinking but I shared some of my
life experience when I was a junior my
girlfriend was a senior and she was
going off to Rikers and I was relatable
and so I created people talk about once
every night I said to my dad then let's
go to the movies my father
what's up and we have the attendant in
conversation only when I told my dad I
know with my girlfriend he said you're
such a loser
going out to the movies I was from I
said I'm so sorry
I love you I was just so afraid you
wouldn't acknowledge a waiter would you
take me back and she did not sure why I
told you that story but figured I'd
share so to start any talk on
storytelling it's best to start with
Plato those who tell the stories rules
society he said he was right then and
he's right now we know that the most
important book ever written in world
history and the biggest blockbuster of
all time the Bible is nothing but an
endless series of stories and some
pretty damn good ones Adam and Eve Cain
and Abel the prodigal son and some
people think the OJ trial may have been
the trial of the century but the trial
of Jesus Christ before the Sanhedrin may
have been the most important in world
history the fact is the four Gospels and
their parables transformed history and
changed the world indeed that's what's
so powerful about the Bible when you
think about it human beings across the
globe have for centuries been stepping
into those stories and seeing ourselves
in them for me it was the story of Jonah
that had the most meaning in my life we
all have at least one story we can point
to in the Bible that draws us closer to
God and to each other stories shape
reality and human beings explain the
great Brooklyn novelist Paul Auster and
the poet Muriel Rukeyser famously said
these words the world is made up of
stories not atoms if they are all
correct
why don't we who care about our nation's
story take the business of storytelling
more seriously
it's odd because we take the business of
every other business in American life
seriously
except the most important one the left
has invested vast fortunes in
storytelling pipelines and fill them
with stories that shape what Americans
think about everything business family
government capitalism our history even
God to understand how we let this happen
we must first understand why we let it
happen first we really don't think
storytelling matters how do I know how
many of us would be happy if a child of
ours told us they wanted to be an actor
or a writer now if that same child told
us they wanted to join the Marine Corps
I know how we'd react we'd be proud at
NYU's Tisch School of the Arts a few
years ago Robert De Niro gave the
commencement speech he told a few jokes
about his craft and then he got serious
he implored the graduates to work hard
and be fearless he reminded them that
they're part of an important tribe
called artists and that their work
matters and shapes the life of their
country De Niro spoke to them they liked
they were new army recruits that's
because the left views careers in the
arts the way we view careers in the
military and business they believe in
this stuff we don't here's the second
reason we failed up till now rather than
invest in storytelling we've spent
billions of dollars on think tanks over
the past few decades on public policy
research those PhDs in their work serve
a vital role no doubt but do we believe
white papers and op-eds can change the
country that facts debate and our
superior arguments alone can change the
narrative of a country when we do spend
money on media we pour billions into
political ads every election cycle what
do we have to show for it
like I said what do we have it's it's
actually tragic because if you think
about this the people who are getting
these advertising dollars Comcast Disney
are the very people who use our
advertising dollars to funnel Jimmy
Kimmel show and pay for all the
entertainment that attacks us or
actually funding our enemies platforms
no disrespect but asking PhDs and
politicians to change the culture is
like asking an NFL linebacker like Clay
Matthews
to be a ballerina rather than to do what
we naturally do in any other business
which is compete we have chosen an
interesting alternative and on a track
and an unattractive one whining and by
the way we end we wind endlessly about
Hollywood media bias and to be fair we
have a lot to whine about when's the
last time you saw a businessman cast as
a good guy and a bureaucrat is the bad
guy on a TV show or a good guy priest
and a bad guy Union boss in a movie a
long time ago actually it was Rod
Steiger playing the corrupt union boss
and call Maldon the heroic priest in
Elia Kazan's 1954 masterpiece on the
waterfront remember the scene where the
dock worker is killed by Union goons for
testifying against their bosses and
there's father Barry in that boat
calling out the bad guys one thug threw
a can at the path at the father's head
another yelled go back to your church
father he yells back this is my church
it made our hand hair sera our heads our
bodies it was so beautiful so why the
stories move people in ways facts and
arguments Canton it's simple human
beings are hard-wired to absorb the
narrative form stories have structure
characters plot themes and emotion all
of which reflect life stories change
hearts they change minds they change
everything that's why it is easy for me
to assert that storytelling is the
world's oldest and best killer app and
stories live in the hearts and minds of
people long after they're told take
Arthur Miller's plays which revolve
mostly around father-son relationships
but always there's that scene that
hammers capitalism like the one in Death
of a Salesman where Willy Loman begs for
his job while his boss plays with a
machine on his desk Miller wrote that
play in 1949 he died in 2006 people are
still moved by that story the power that
media ownership confers to the left on
the storytelling front is profound and
the biggest advantage is this they
choose the stories that get told but
much more important they choose the
stories that don't get told that
curation power affects outcomes if
artists want their stories chosen they'd
best comport with the curators worldview
which drives artists to censor
themselves without even knowing it
because they need the work that's why so
many artists are liberal their bosses
are another power of media ownership is
its asymmetric nature a handful of
owners make the majority of us feel as
if we're minorities in our own country
it's why dictators always seize the
media because what they're seizing is
their nation's story
sadly the leftist did that did that but
not by force we just kind of let him
back in 2004 the often Louisa Lim
visited four beijing universities what
would happen he wondered when he showed
students a photo of tank man would they
recognize it you know the iconic picture
the lone man two shopping bags and hands
standing in front of a line of Tanks and
defiance of the crackdown by the Chinese
government at Tiananmen Square in 1989
it turned out that only 15% of the
Beijing students recognized the picture
that wasn't an accident
as Lim explained in his book the
People's Republic of amnesia Tiananmen
revisited the Chinese authorities were
determined to blot out public memory of
the protests George Orwell knew why he
said this the most effective way to
destroy a people is to obliterate their
understanding of their own history in
America we have a different problem many
on the Left who
care for America capitalism or the
Constitution work harder to promote the
most shameful aspects of our story while
erasing from public memory our most
positive aspects it's China in Reverse
and a very different kind of amnesia is
setting in we conservatives on a few mat
foot media platforms Fox News talk radio
some websites but it's mostly news and
opinion it's programming design to feed
the choir and to preach to the choir not
grow it we've invested little and
storytelling platforms that will attract
new fans to this great brand called
America and where the businesspeople
where the smart guys in spoken word
formats the storytelling elephant in the
room is NPR they have 30 million people
listening and 350 million in annual
revenue with only 10% coming from the
government and PR also dominates the
podcast world with five of the top ten
podcasts in the country several years
ago with the help of some national
donors and Hillsdale College a team of
storytellers got together to launch a
non-profit alternative to NPR and a
daily two-hour syndicated storytelling
show one that celebrates America and the
events and people who made the country
great from the arts to sports and
business to history our American stories
was designed to tell the story of
America to Americans many of the stories
revolve around character resilience and
the power and persistence and imagine of
imagination this is a story about an
improbable story about an author of
America's songbook few people write as
many hits fewer still write as many
standards fewer still writes songs that
become part of our national identity
white Christmas and God bless america
both of which this one man wrote are a
part of our cultural DNA he did it
without formal training he couldn't read
or write music and play it almost
entirely in the key of F sharp because
it was easier for his untrained fingers
to play the elevated well spaced Black
Keys he said this the Black Keys are
right under your fingers the key of C is
for people who study music
Irving
this story is about many things hardwork
adversity
creativity but America itself he was
born Israel
Valene in Russia in 1888 one of eight
children and son to a cantor in the
local synagogue his family fled Russia
after their village was destroyed in an
anti-semitic pogrom Berlin's only memory
was of his father quote lying in a
blanket by the side of a road watching
his house burned to the ground his
family settled in New York but there
would be more tragedy to come in young
earrings life none was worse than the
loss of his father when he was 8 it was
at a job waiting tables to support his
family that he discovered a particular
talent his tips skyrocketed when he hung
songs of the day singing a table soon
turned into a lifetime of songwriting in
1911 his Alexander's ragtime band
climbed to number 2 on the Billboard
charts but ragtime wasn't his thing he
wanted to create his own version of
American music something romantic that
appeared appeal to the masses he did
just that he wrote over 1,500 songs he
told his biographer he didn't believe in
inspiration and it his most successful
compositions were the result of hard
work one of his successes started as a
failure berlin wrote god bless america
originally in 1918 while serving in the
army but he couldn't find a buyer in
1938 as hitler was rising to power
berlin pulled that song out of his
drawer Kate Smith recorded it and the
rest was history Berlin's daughter wrote
that her father meant every word of that
song quote it was the land he loved it
was his home sweet home he the immigrant
who made good was saying thank you to
his country writing one anthem would be
enough for any mourning but in 1941
Berlin wrote another white Christmas
which would sell 50 million copies for
Bing Crosby and become the best-selling
single of all time and one of the
world's most beloved Christmas songs
those two anthems may be the most
compelling
aspect of Berlin's legacy a Jew wrote
white Christmas and a Russian wrote god
Bless America and he was the same damn
guy only in America is such a thing
possible folks only in America is Irving
Berlin's life possible he died at the
age of 101 a wealthy man in large part
because he owned his own publishing
catalog America's artist Berlin included
our debt of gratitude to our nation's
founders who secured not just property
rights but intellectual property too and
the freedom to write about anything
without recourse from their own
government it is why American artists
are the most prolific in the world
because they're the freest in the world
and live in a place where their ideas
are protected - and by our nation's
founder in the Constitution itself
article 1 the next story is about that
founder as it wasn't any founder who
wanted to protect ideas he was a founder
who worked hard to protect ideas through
something called a patent because he was
himself an inventor a writer and a
publisher Benjamin Franklin understood
the power of ideas more importantly he
understood the value of ideas he became
a very rich man from Poor Richard's
Almanack the story reflects a deep
division the one I'm about to tell you
within an hour not yet formed country a
division that split not just fellow
countrymen but families too and the
consequences for choosing a side in this
division was not simply a tweet storm or
a Facebook post quote an awful silence
pervaded the houses we were called up
one after another to the table of the
president of Congress Benjamin Rush said
Benjamin Rush said to sign what was
believed by many at the time to be our
own death warrant rush was right
the British government considered the
Declaration of Independence a treasonous
document and treason was a capital crime
how divided was America one look at
Benjamin Franklin's family tells the
story the printer inventor writer and
diplomat was dry was the driving force
of the American enlightenment but his
own
was torn apart by our first Civil War
Franklin's son William was illegitimate
but he had all the advantages than any
other boy in this world could want
throughout their lives father and son
were extremely close Franklin even used
his influence to secure his son the
royal governorship of New Jersey neither
man could have imagined they'd one day
be forced to choose between king and
country
the father joined the cause of the
Patriots late and urged his son to join
him William insisted that dad joined the
loyalists that choice led to the son's
arrest and a two-year stint in the worst
prison in America the Litchfield gaol in
Connecticut quote it was a destination
of last resort for outlaws condemned to
be hanged convicted murderers reprobates
and traitors wrote historian David
Epstein after his release from prison
William emigrated to England never to
return home a few years before his death
Ben Franklin received a letter from his
son who was hoping for a chance at
reconciliation the father wrote back
promptly and imagined getting this kind
of a letter from your dad quote nothing
has hurt me so much son and affected me
with such keen sensation is to find
myself deserted in my old age by my only
son and not only deserted but to find
him taking up arms against me in a cause
where in my good fame fortune and life
or all at stake that was it the two men
would never reconcile Franklin died a
wealthy man he left his son nothing the
political divide today is still about
power in a distant City but that distant
city isn't London it's Washington DC
it's a fight we've been having since our
founding fights about power fights about
sovereignty that last story was situated
in the 18th century this next is about
one of America's great 20th century
leaders Martin Luther King his Christian
faith was an animating force in his life
as was the book he dedicated his life
study to the Bible Bill Maher the
comedian once described the Bible as a
book most Christians don't actually
read he said this it's like a software
license Christian scroll down to the
bottom and click I agree Martin Luther
King thought differently the Bible
wasn't a software license it was
software code a deep mysterious code
authored by a God for man's eternal
purposes indeed he found the Bible so
compelling King so relevant in the 20th
century that his undergraduate degree
and PhD were both in Bible studies
leaving God out of Martin Luther King's
life story and the Bible is like leaving
automobiles out of Henry Ford's life or
hamburgers at every crux but that's
precisely what the media does at every
turn every year when they celebrate his
life take the last night of King's life
as he headed into Memphis in 1968 he
knew he was in danger quote there's no
way you can keep somebody from killing
you he told reporters if they really
want to kill you bomb threats delayed
his flight into Memphis that night and
though King was troubled he told
supporters quote I'd rather be dead than
afraid then came his speech at the Mason
temple the night of April 3rd it was as
if the 39 year old knew his life will
soon end a major theme of that speech
was fear and by the way is it not a
major theme of the Bible the other was
the story of the Good Samaritan a
parable told by Jesus in the Gospel of
Luke King told the audience about a trip
he and his wife made along the Jericho
Road and why he thought two men passed a
stranger in need and why one didn't
quote and this is from the Sermon
directly it's a winding meandering
dangerous road conducive to ambushing he
told the audience and you know it's
possible that the priest and the Levite
looked over at that man on the ground
and wondered if the robbers was still
around or it's possible they felt the
man on the ground was acting like he'd
been robbed and hurt in order to lure
them there for easy seizure and so the
first question Levi asked was as I
stopped to help this man what will
happen to me then the Good Samaritan
came by and he reversed the question if
I don't stop to help the
man what will happen to him that's the
question before you tonight King
preached a few minutes later the speech
which it by now turned into a sermon
started it's prophetic turn like anybody
he said I'd like to live a long life
longevity has its place but I'm not
concerned about that now I just want to
do God's will
King told the spellbound audience he's
allowed me to go up to the mountaintop
and I've looked over it and I've seen
the promised land and I may not get
there with you but I want you to know
tonight that as we have people will in
the end finally we will get to the
promised land on the eve of April 4th
not long before he was gunned down at
the Lorraine hotel in Memphis Kings last
words were to a musician named Ben
branch who was scheduled to perform in
an event later later on that night Ben
he said make sure you play take my hand
precious Lord play it real slow play it
pretty the enduring truth of this story
one the media cannot rewrite is this
Martin Luther King's desire to serve the
God he loved changed forever the country
he loved this last story that I'm about
to tell you is a story of a city and a
disaster the Great Chicago Fire of 1871
and the even more remarkable story of
the great chicago recovery experts
disagree on how that fire started some
say it was a cow others say it was
vandals but everyone agrees on why the
fire started
it was Chicago's remarkable growth in
1840 the city had a mere forty five
hundred residents ten years later had
passed the 30,000 mark by 1860 it had
grown to 100,000 and by 1870 300,000
what led to all that growth as the
saying goes location Location Location
chicago is near the center of the
country near where the waterways and
railways met it was a perfect place for
anything and anyone to get anywhere
timing also played a part
America was going through a
transformation from a rural power to an
industrial power
but how did all of that growth all of
that life lead to a near-death
experience as a Chicago historian
explained Chicago had to build quickly
so they built it all out of wood it was
quick and easy and cheap Mother Nature
played her part to a meteorologist Tom
skilling said quote it was an
exceedingly dry summer and fall or still
winter was approaching and those wood
houses were filled with firewood the
Chicago Fire it turns out wasn't just
predictable it was inevitable it started
out on the west side and quickly roared
out of control a steady wind propelling
the inferno from block to block and even
across the Chicago River 30 hours later
the fire finally ran out of fuel because
there was nothing left to burn the fire
claimed nearly 300 lives a third of the
city lay in ruins and 100,000 people
were homeless most of the hotels stores
and banks were destroyed by the way
that's a State Street a picture in a
second we'll show you that same shot
same angle 20 years later what happened
next revealed the character of the city
and the nation there was no FEMA back
then no Illinois Emergency Management no
one to blame no one to sue and no
appetite for victimhood even before the
bricks stopped smoking the city's
leaders were planning a comeback the
Reverend Robert Collier told his
congregation these words we have not
lost our geography nature called the
lakes the forests and the prairies
together in convention long before we
were born and they have decided that on
this spot a great city would be rebuilt
within 48 hours 12 of the 29 banks that
burned down were operating in makeshift
facilities to get money to customers
bankers got busy raising Capital One
sent letters to bankers all over the
globe
urging them to invest and loan money to
the great people of Chicago Chicago was
rebuilt at an unimaginable pace by 1880
its population reached 500,000 and by
1890 it passed the 1 million mark
becoming the second big
city in America same street same camera
angle the people of Chicago did all of
it without the help of the state or
federal government American optimism
resilience character and capitalism
itself rebuilt the city folks we must
start telling the story of America to
Americans stories about all its good and
decent and beautiful about this country
we must address matters of the heart -
not talking about love is where we all
go wrong because it's love that builds a
city we must tell stories about faith -
and the beautiful things we do because
of our faith America is unimaginable
without it because the battle lines in
America are not just between left and
right in the end they're between up
versus down and that is the material
world versus the spiritual world folks
to continue to let the left alone tell
the story of America isn't just gross
negligence its cultural suicide
we have great stories to tell let's
start telling them how hard can it be
after all liberals do it that's all
folks
[Applause]
sure it's a wonderful thing that you're
doing but let me tell you as a writer
what the difficulties are editors
publishers are looking for a certain
point of view and it's hard to even get
through the front door I was a
nationally syndicated columnist in 122
papers the generation of today course I
was a different generation doesn't want
to talk to me because of my point of
view the grants that you try to go for
as far as the internships the money that
even the government gives has a
different point of view that the
newspapers are owned media why aren't we
buying why aren't we buying them why
aren't we spending money in order to
create our own market as far as
storytelling is concerned so those are
just some of the things that I would
like you to address if you have any
ideas in 1996 we got a fire
MSNBC's believe it or not to do a TV
show on MSNBC back when nobody was
watching it and they pretended not to be
the only I was stuck in Secaucus New
Jersey all day and it was visible and
everybody was livable but there was a
show in the morning well the dynami show
and lore and I learned a lot about radio
we got into radio but in 1996 15-year
heard head starts CNN had a guy named
Roger Ailes got together with a
billionaire named Rupert Murdoch and
they decided to slide a lot of money up
to the table and say let's compete and
they competed and Fox News won and I'd
seen it happening and in the end let's
take a film directors and I think we all
know and love
plenty since 1991 Clint Eastwood has
done 22 or 23 points I'm not sure which
eight have been number one or number two
and over a billion dollars in the box
office
he is total creative control his movies
and what why not they make money I think
we're getting to a place now where a lot
of our donors and investors spent a lot
of money on political ads and a lot of
money another place
starting to think harder about
storytelling and the good news is that
the barrier to entry are much lower than
they used to be muscle release me and
there's just tremendous demand I mean
that every Clint Eastwood movies number
one or number two
think about the Unforgiven think about
Gran Torino I mean there was a movie
with the Catholic priest who was trying
to be good trying to influence the old
Craig Baxter right and he would have
thought he was a particle except what
does he do these total strangers we
didn't like really insulting routinely
the end of the bloody willing his
perfect perfect party and in an act of
self-sacrifice gets himself shot to free
that family from thugs and gangsters it
was a beautiful and Americans great evil
and our capitalist assembly starts
stepping up to the plate and putting the
money up and that's why we're doing what
we're doing
there's one success in Makena many
successes or over I'll leave you with
this one of the things that's missing is
executive talent there are two publicly
traded companies in America that are run
by conservatives Fox News and sell media
and I'm the VP of content at sell
immediately if and when I decided to
leave that position a very nice paying
position that finish will be filled
because so many other jobs are out there
for me and meet them none
I leave this day and I'm a little mango
to start my own thing there's 25 of
their jobs if I decide to Chuck drop
back in so I think these are things we
know we have to address and we're about
to start
- I got so tired of complaining and wine
delivery that I hadn't talked to captain
Weston they liked the idea there is some
it said go ahead so I think this is more
about us not complaining in the not
whining about our circumstance I mean
goodness watch you can look down into
the into the into the Brooklyn partner
and sir - an armada coming in slightly
more difficult problem so I just think
that the word Stockholm Syndrome always
itches to be visited you know my wife
had been sexually abused for six years
and I said well how why didn't you leave
and she said did you stunned you start
to identify when they have to be after
gets in your head and pretty soon your
stuff and the real power of the media is
that rule and this sort of Stockholm
Syndrome like okay we keep speaking the
media coming at us and we think it's
hopeless
meanwhile we keep winning elections we
heard the garage Obama at Google and he
had Facebook and the ascendancy of the
digital social revolution of the lead to
a democratic Germany and the tea party
Amon and swept Reagan had nobody pretty
formal it was just NBC ABC and CBS they
were all rooting against him there was
no Fox News there was no drug there was
no nothing
he won 49 states in his second race so
the American people just need to be fed
and I think we're trying to prove that
with our with our properties but I know
the problem I have the facts
Lauren I'm trying to start there was no
talk radio I mean there was maybe one
talk station in every fish market and it
was until 2001 we got that my syndicated
Hannity that's indicated that got
syndicated suddenly there was a lot of
content this is something a lot of talk
stations to park that country and by the
way you want to talk about a big serving
a conservative dial on this forty five
million people visiting conservative
talk radio and it is made all the
difference in the world we have come to
dominate operated in a way that no
liberal no left this kind of imagine I
remember and I'm sure all you do the
first time you heard that prior Rush
Limbaugh even thanks he finally finally
someone's talking my language so we make
the movies that people they'll come no
question that we go with no come next
Oh God
you know about the glint what was on
Laura showing she's always has to meet
the questions because we love to get the
office comfortable and then we ask them
the singer and well we hadn't seen her
for now this of course when he was
writing his book about David and Goliath
he told a really great story and he
talked about how David prepared for
here's who those five smooth stones and
how quiet I was stumbling and Mercer and
the diamond and all the advantages in
Goliath didn't just the new games about
speed not about size you think they
don't do any of that you think David got
there and on that battle just doesn't
all that preparation so she let him
alcohol by nobody but now and I'd love
one thing out of his book Damon had gone
on inside and he knew it
this helps so God gives me hope and
other campuses actually gives me hope I
live in Oxford Mississippi that's where
you are Joe and I see young people
battling back in their own ways often
just through just one of these to the
campus protesters and I think sometimes
we give the temperance protesters a
little too much credit I don't like
what's happening at our campuses but our
young people are smart not found Ronald
Reagan I gotcha
everybody told me Oh young people
operating they me so luckily we talked
he was gonna push man off the cliff
he was gonna get us into a nuclear war
he was an actor he was an idiot he was
lazy I mean the prevailing theme about
Reagan was that he was gonna lose and
you know nobody was gonna vote for me
while back order form Laura diamond
wrote informed initiatives every young
person I know his JD Carter was saying
the from America's best days are a great
country we're a great people it so I
think half of our problem is us we walk
around acting as if we're losing from
the wind and we act like we have no
moment and this is what the left does of
their media control does best of all
look at if you believe that there's a
god lives were saving Satan wants to
steal your joy in the command so worried
we're working on behalf of the left
we're loving we're reaching out and
we're telling stories we're reaching out
to our neighbors there's the light once
a year I'll tell you a story once here
there's this Lebanese professor at Ole
Miss would advise me so I get to speak
to five hundred kids the faculty goes
crazy he doesn't hear his tenure he's a
Christian is a conservative goes
so I get 500 kids in the room something
interesting that's headlights all I've
ever did in Kosovo
I'd say how I need you believe in the
thing called love even though it's not
provable even though those scientists
can measure how many you believe in a
thing called love every single angle and
by the way I'm gonna have a look and I'm
filming and so now I said keep your eyes
closed
how many of you if you met the proper
person in your life within and it was
your soul mate or sowing you really
thought you could spend the rest to go
out of heaven you want to get married
almost all day and stayed off be still
my heart almost totally dreaming all
these kids for different walks of life
all different children one did their
homework one thing all don't work
one was dutiful and then he had another
who didn't do anything stake the room
play by the music and just play video
games did you do any chores how many of
you would different the singles not a
single animal said I said raise your
hands
I said let's play the video who said we
don't agree on a lot of things and then
I asked questions did you create
inequality but then one didn't know and
someone midnight and is it a bad thing
and I asked just a few more questions
and what the headline of like 300 kids
going did you teach you and I give an
answer I just ask you a bunch of
questions and Chris bachelor and I Chris
isn't on the board of a
telling me a story about watching them
Friedman back when he was at the
University of Michigan and watch he know
the treatment pond of all places of the
language googly put up and they'll treat
all authority who's doing is asking
questions in a proper series and felony
is like gesticulating by the time five
or six minutes bestest don't nothing
doesn't know what to do with himself
because he can't his answer a series of
very simple questions so I have
tremendous hope not only for the country
we got down on her side we've got the
Constitution so I've got an amazing
people and I got to tell you there's we
had the immigration on our side we told
one story about a chinese-american who
did the thought experiment he was
wondering how many Americans trying to
become Chinese citizens so he said so he
knows through the process and he's going
through the process he discovers about a
single American that year he tried to
become a Chinese citizen so that it
called some powers that he had has he
done to some overseas fancy school and
it turns out they were doing the fog
experiment it wasn't a person in Europe
who tried to become Chinese citizen and
at the end of this book was sort of a
story that he told us he said you know
I'm so hopeful about America but this
work great in creating Chinese Americans
but Americans believe Tainan is really
bad at creating American Chinese and
this is true and so this is our
advantage the world wants to come and no
and I love it the love says were a
racist nation and yet all these
dark-skinned immigrants
come here to play my Lebanese and
Sicilian nurse so now their claims are
false they they get us to angry if we
were a little more confident in our step
we do it yes you mentioned the old days
a lot of things that we like about
America were there at the beginning but
that's not where they started
is there ever a need to not just tell
America's stories but the stories that
made America what it was so for every
story we tell about George Washington
which will do will tell a story about
some young Venezuelan immigrant who left
the oil patch of it as well this
particular gentleman left when Hugo
Chavez consolidated the organization and
why he left was because the moment he
consolidated oil industry Chavez has
panels all got the jobs and the
competent people all left because well
you know what happens when nepotism was
the day he confidence wins confidence is
punished so they said what the heck
let's get out of here let's go to the
oil
- no money - the rain he had his friends
work hard cleaned trapping trunks bought
a couple of frightening trucks and now
run a multi-million dollar business and
so connecting our best to our president
and why did that happened he start to
talk about property rights he started to
talk about that though he started
talking about how a contract meant so
now these are things we take the rent in
Louisville you know we play this piece I
think it's almost worth playing if I can
find it we do an hour on Justice
Scalia's life every year we'd shaylen's
what what is the left on nine
documentaries by now on RPG for tenant I
mean this never would have comes out
every day I walked out of Ole Miss of
the the the the one doctor in terms of
being played there because I don't on
the see the reaction to see what the
professor's did they had about a
thousand people that are lost for a
bunch of documentary about Pittsburgh
and as I walked out I'm just talking to
some of the students lot of undergrads a
lot of people community they were just
so horrified when I asked them hey did
you know that Peter kids Berg wasn't the
first female Supreme Court justice it
was like wonderful pictures into their
and that was it then we did a story
about Scalia in his own words and not
just about the Constitution right I mean
he's spoken about so many things in so
many places and when people hear his
Scalia talk it's just a remarkable thing
the most powerful thing of it the day
before he died the day after he died we
asked people for their favorites billion
stories and this one gentleman who
writes for the Acton Institute told this
story about how he would go to church
fairly regularly on a weekday afternoon
in the same church near the core
temperature physically Lenten and one
day the church was pretty empty he was
standing in the back Scalia didn't
notice him he didn't notice Philly at
first but then he saw the justice he saw
a woman walk up to the Justice who
looked I see it said like kind of only
devoid on the street sores on our hands
open swords homeless person the troubled
person he said he said I watched Justice
Scalia but his offering I watched
Justice Scalia stroker shorter own I
watched him touch her whisper words of
evasion order to come to her for about
five minutes and then whatever he said
did we sure look like he
again tapped her on the patents Rutger
back sent her on her way and then he
went on his way and he said and then I
saw man a beautiful man who was honoring
his God and doing it the way God
humanity was just illustrating if we
don't tell stories about this not just
the jurisprudence of Scalia but the man
still in we're doing a tremendous
disservice and while they dropped off
ensberg and we're silently within with
with Scalia we're just we have ourselves
playing so those are the kind of things
we just love to do and we don't like to
connect our core is attest to the
president I don't know if any of you
have seen the country music special
unlike the nerves but I heard - all
again see it's absolutely remarkable and
when you really feel is to get close to
the country and you could tell feminism
had just discovered this thing called
country news if you recall this first
documentary on American music and he's
done maybe 20 by now but he's first rose
on jazz because he's a senior so he
actually thought Janet was America's
music only it never was because he never
thought this was too complex too
highbrow for the average
now country music in rock'n'roll with
the American music this is what America
let's talk to mrs.
humidex work to the law and we're
selling like crazy overs interesting
publicity of the country musicians is
they all had a deep respect and
reverence for their for their
predecessors they all knew every Bill
Monroe song they all knew every chin
handsome and yet they also wanted to
take that country music their
predecessors great art and move it to
another place so both loving the
formation of character and necessity of
the rock country to country and yet
never made America arm so we want to
love George Washington but we want to
say this is our country now how do we
take the principles of the Constitution
the rule of law and apply it to our life
I've never been create our culture among
Christians particularly and
conservatives have good enough in
asserting our own cultural identity we
have simply had an identify reaction to
the oppressors
identity and our identity has become a
reaction of identity and that's a shame
because we have so much that so much so
much to believe in and identity at some
attractiveness there's this basically
this stories are built on lies in the
end and ours are built on truth and
there was a last woman when he Marcel's
is sitting there talking about country
music and waited believe it or not this
is so crazy but an African American jazz
composer
our best musicians it's one of the
regular people talking to this in our
country music special and he starts to
talk about Hank Williams and he talks
about the songs writers listen to that
lonely welcome voice listen to that pain
listen to that suffering my wife didn't
be more my husband did me wrong I left
my goddamn when I didn't let my god damn
God love faith fear we black people were
always singing you know external stuff
why are we talking about that - or all
human beings this is what Marsellus
condemning it's only people it is all
music for me superficially for being
external and for not talking about our
own personal citizen families which is
what country music does better than any
other musical idiom nomes man it's a
confession of great countries just a
pure confessional most black music is
the protest it says nothing about the
person in their sentence it says in
questions other nuances which is what
wouldn't Marcel stop making empty empty
that's man one last question yes
Division of our American stories was
renewed we're interested any for a team
to be in those fibers sure five years
ago I was at a conference for why it
seemed untie company Bill Bennett of all
the people I spent a lot of time on bill
had the most intact above me animal
Laura Bill Bennett's first her Laura's
her struggles were building in the
Reagan and the Reagan administration
writing speeches Portman and Bill just
has a way of mentoring people and and
demanding that they we he wants us to
read and so I said you read that book
did you read that book any that you'd be
like me I mean ability to make me feel
like more but it's good he doesn't do it
kind of saying that he's challenging you
all the time to be so easy he has this
speech the typical stuff speech but on
this [ __ ] into a bag that was really
rough so that ladies tpc speaking of
Florida 100 like that the movers and
shakers of Florida
and he just goes up straight and he
gives a talk about the American story
and now we're losing the narrative and I
mean it was just he was not happy by the
way the audience was memory mesmerized
but I'm sitting there and everybody's
looking at me then the next day what we
have what we call our selves in and
Torrio meetings you spread all the hosts
and some outside writers join bills that
and again
are we moving the needle via destiny
especially some of the scene
presidents are we changing it we do it
when he was really sending one but we
bringing new people in the choir
oh we grow on market and I think they do
the answer and in some ways it was just
about at that time when the chorus the
conservative course was starting to pick
that itself so you weren't just growing
the choir
we're actually sort of dividing and
splitting up the water
Ryan oh those teeth Marcus getting that
but we're all just killing each other
and and so I took me personally I really
wasn't doing so the next day I just
thought don't look what's that all about
and he said you know you know what would
this American like the end of your
product which he loved he said what
would this american life sound like that
the people making it like that and that
was it for me i went back to our CEO the
head of sale - what boss on that
equipment engineer because i got this
thing on one dude and he said come away
from these shows just make this be
another show go do what you do step it
up that's like it's a non-profit and i
went to was the founder of the federal
society i Cheryl in the vision I went to
doctor or a share of the division and I
got to Bernie Marcus founder home people
and she'll Angela so a really remarkable
Christian philanthropist and they both
gave the cPanel
though so what we're doing now is
building into our day national
storytelling channel on radio because
that's some of the people are and then
ultimately when they look like this what
we hope to do is have got the nothing
little property enough stories about all
kinds of Americans that one day we could
go to a Netflix or somebody like that
and say hey we've got hundreds and
hundreds of hours of content we've got a
whole lot of families the stories have
been written and we'd like to just film
I'd also love a vision would be to have
a bunch of the people who work for me at
one day in the future say hey I want to
start my own sure I'm going to start my
own and then I will done the best
service to my donors which is to train a
new generation and executives because
this is a business we heard this in the
country special all the time country
music is business
if you don't sell records then you don't
have a career and then if you don't go
to war you don't have a career the less
really good at this they take this
business really seriously and that's
that's the plan is to just go do
something big and have a big cultural
impact we try not to be on talk radio
stations we want to be on country
stations we want to be on classic rock
stations that when somebody hears the
story of Henry Ford didn't oh my
goodness I did not know that he got
wealthy lowering the price apart and
then cars which were you - not available
to TVs 50 years ago and then were only
available to the rich whenever available
internally and when we explain
capitalism
that that nothing else didn't lower the
prices up and make it better in Cheney
than equity through competition through
free enterprise and through the end
consumers choosing who wins and who
loses not by force but by traitors by
the way this resonates with people when
I talk to kids in schools and I talk to
about life as it is I just you know I
like one day I played a clip Barack
Obama and Obama had said in 2009 what we
need to do is take all the insurance
dollars get rid of the profits of each
one get rid of the market in each one
fold them into one of their parts and
then we'll be more efficient and I went
anybody here to think there's a problem
what he just said they didn't really
wash it out I said to think about your
own models think about flat-screen TVs
and I'm gonna pick you up for the first
flat-screen TV and the first box between
TV cost like $15,000 how much cheaper
they need so I said now look at all the
companies that are making what we need
there are a whole bunch of companies
some succeeded something let's look at
the data check took a picture of retaken
Shabaab look at all those different
potato chips all the different profits
all the men are
all the procedures what with the potato
chip pile of monthly if the federal
government made one rotation the natural
potato gun those would be good potato
chips do you think they need cheap
advantages what part of your life
doesn't free markets by the way this is
astounding to them because I'm not
telling you to be a Republican I'm not
telling me to be a Democrat I try not to
use word capitalism because it just
means so many bad things but when I just
talk about freedom and they're online
it's a why they choose one restaurant
another what would happen if there was
one government restaurant oh that's
right it's the commissary and you don't
eat their food so the Constitution on
our site where mystery on assignment is
but really crummy that this thing won't
believe and if we just dare to play in
the space we take fifty percent market
share in ten years because in the
country nice and I actually think we get
a lot of these centuries Democrat stupid
this is troublesome I think that a lot
more people would be hospitable to our
ideas if they met us first through story
rather than to a politician
well I can tell you this is a topper
because my father was Italian and it's a
Puccini play bulletin but I'm agree my
friends and they'd sort of like the
genie but then in ruins and it couldn't
compete so and every Belinda said this
best just when he hated said look I want
to make westphall Americans and I think
in the end our bicycle American you can
use Copeland and it's Dylan and it just
interested so I would say that classical
jazz and the urban affordable because
it's subsidized and then they can say
it's educational but if you own some of
the only places we now have the
classical music well in the Bible and I
love it but it's it's almost it's almost
done and only the only sort of a few
leads lead neighborhoods have so it's
mostly cities that play the classical
music and then the price you pay for
having
music is having to listen to fresh air
and it's also sorry
it's animatable the sanitary group and
by the way notice NPR's it's global
warming now I mean it is just non-stop
sustainability and LGBTQIA I mean it
just never ends even marked a place
which is supposed to be about the
economy is never about the weather so
you can't even make it up but it is what
it is it is NPR is actually a ministry
it is a ministry right people are doing
it and that's their church and it's a
secular ministry a secular progressive
nation and what we're trying to do here
is call this we have initiative our
American stories will be a throw rule of
law prohibited ministry that loves free
enterprise you got and so my feeling has
always been if it's 30 Marcus told me
he's one of my heroes he started on Bebo
he said it's so much easier to do lowers
and only the guy who comes out in the
Billups the market goes out of it and
then locals just sits around those let's
just copy them debone take 30% of the
market share
let's steal some of their executives and
let's you know hope some of their
members and so in the end here's and
they are doing something
don't what they do right let's do many
and let's just order her her centromere
this stuff they did and just do a medic
I'm very hopeful of his innovative
disruptors and entrepreneurs are just
starting to enter into this space and if
I can inspire a few that'll be even more
important than making the content itself
is inspiring others to innovate in space
[Applause]